suite bonjour merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france donald trump
donc testé positif aux qu'ovide 19
finalement le président américain a été
rattrapé par par la maladie alors qu'il
clamait haut et fort que voilà elle
n'était pas contagieuse et sans danger
oui donc le premier à reprendre c'est
que c'est la justice poétique
voilà dans nos trente qui a qui a dit
que il est immunisé par les hydro un
club hydroxyque lors queen ou que c'est
une craie muller et a maintenant il est
testée positive ou deux mois c'est que
ça quitte à monter il faut se méfier
maintenant de toutes les annonces de
maison blanche tout est un communication
dans le but d'une stratégie delek à
l'hectare et ça pourrait être le cas qu
il n'a pas ou que cet homme dans deux
semaines il dit voilà c'est rien du tout
voyez j'étais pas digéré haine de tout
mais c'est certain qu'il pourra le
jardin leurs valises et il y adeux
justice poétique
justement on est à quelques semaines de
l'élection présidentielle
comment cette annonce peut-elle jouer
justement dans ses futures actions
oui d'une sens strictement le prima
facie c'est que ça montre que dans notre
ombre peuvent être touchées à la réalité
par le cog hill et d'une façon qu'il se
présente comme soupiraux ça pourrait
jouer marc et bien sûr s'ils taisent
positive il commence à voir les fantômes
ça pour ça pourrait lui même tué dans ce
cas l'élection soit dans le chaos
mais je crois qu'il est assez fort il a
une bonne constitution et probablement
ils ne m'aiment pas aller vers la même
direction que boris johnson ils le sont
de beaux restes en selle après avoir
attrapé le coc vide
il commence être sérieuse dans le
politique publique
il se sort ça se sensibilise et a donc
peut-être pendant la campagne
après avoir pris le kobe dans l'autre
entreprendre sérieuse le genre de cette
can demi avant le deuxième vague et nous
sommes en pleine campagne présidentielle
on sait que donald trump est au plus bas
dans les sondages est ce que cette
annonce peut justement faire remonter sa
cote de popularité à votre avis
intéressant oui les sympathies c'est
vrai un des horizons mille îles et
clément a hissé qu'il est agressive est
forte et la faiblesse peuvent toucher un
certain nombre d indépendance entier
clairement parmi eux qui sont déjà que
due à une carence de cette maladie oui
ça pourrait s'appeler ray pourrait
induire le sympathique mais je pense pas
maintenant c'est un ami ce régime c'est
la justice poétique et j'attende le pire
moi non je n'aime que personne soit
marrade de ça en tout cas il n'a
toujours pas eu de réactions on va bien
évidemment détaillé un petit peu plus
cette nouvelle dans nos futures éditions
merci en tout cas de glace ayasse
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes professeur de
droit et spécialiste de sciences
politiques américains